yeah hello and welcome please vo Clank
cranky lamp from Azerbaijan right a bit
of a late start header in issue with
them with the window I observed the game
Annette screwed up the window somehow I
had to rearrange to the recording so
let's see what Frankie lambeth up to
yeah this is not a particularly great
line for black but we'll see what
happens he goes into a bad structure MP
down so okay so we'll be five is the
idea I guess let's see I probably have
to do this j5 so let's see what he does
on the queenside so going to go e six
who maybe is to activate something or
eat I've the interesting question if i
should take on water but normal is to
not take and just rearrange the pieces
correctly night to d3 so it's going to
close this now the a5 pond is a bit weak
let's see i'm not sure here what's going
on
and make sure they want to play age
three here or not it could be wrong and
we've got some counter play with nijah
form okay probably not and if five is
weakness now letting okay also night h7
I will push this Wow have a hard time to
understand anything in so isn't this
just good for White Knight f3 and then
five looks looks good shall not or not I
cannot go if I've now though
hmm I Scott Bishop g4 it's a good move
its completion g-form look 81 if he
takes it in five is ok am but he's got
Bishop g4 lets you have to play for that
now that's much better than then taking
the unimportant pawn on e5 and now each
five Bishop takes isn't isn't that great
to beat yeah it's not as good as I
thought really not
I wonder about five takes Bishop chicks
there are some interesting tactics at
the end but okay I have to play move now
and not wait for alpha for ages you can
probably just take and play 19-5 that's
a very likely anthem and with this one
is also interesting there and now I'm
stuck with the pawn yeah I am NOT a
depth it works it's badness now now I
now know I'm in bad shape that I played
badly really did and it started out as
an excellent position for me really did
but I'm is plated
I completely plate that ok bit surprised
about this I thought I would be quite
happy with the gate 6 pawn being one
isn't this good so if i take it and
write 18 may have to take unfortunately
try to get to e7 and d7 he wants to
wants to run tonight 54 attack I g4 is
also good this idea
king of age king of age yeah okay many
cannot so easily move the night as rupee
ADA's an annoying friend is annoying I
want to go hook before and then 94 now
that's a good idea okay hi Maddie in
this a bit annoying because it's just
this is just a good position for wide
very good for white but I did not play
it correctly I mean this is can never be
good yeah I mean we should one be seven
and so on so I should be better here in
this position and he wants to take and
play six now that didn't occur to me
until I should take I know that a porn
is a bit of a nuisance than that that it
is son needed to protect I mean so
obviously the way it went it wasn't good
so I have to improve I mean I can always
play this yeah but that isn't too
convincing look F to you want mr.
engines move probably preparing night at
3am I mean the way the way it was played
I was banking on a creepy five and I
couldn't make it work so look a to you
wanna
493 something like that is not going to
be good then that's just an excellent
structure on the king size white all
pieces work together perfectly and that
that the problem is that it doesn't
doesn't quite work really and I don't
get invited anyone is still correct so
in fact I was briefly thinking about
this but I didn't see that he cannot
move the bishop so that was still good
for wine and must have been good for I
mean I don't believe this like night
here and the bed structure how can that
be good yeah I can be good if you miss
stuff if I this just this is terrible
now Black is fine quickly me to is
pretty bad I have to play inside yeah I
actually saw this idea because i'm on
the spawn but i didn't see that you
cannot take at all because I threaten on
x7 this is the thing when I did not see
as disastrous look like if I get a pawn
to e6 now and now the position is just
bad and it's it it's awful to play in
addition and i'm actually not not that
sure how it's the way it went King age
12 in a foil and so and this is I of
course I I hope turn at the porn air but
he gets it back and now
it's just a log back on I had to push
push the pawn that was just a very bad
move clean the two was very bad what I
actually miss is that it can play will
be five right away which is completely
stopping me five I mean this is ok not
very okay in fact nobody six coming it's
not a problem at all to be a pawn down
yeah fine okay thanks for watching guys